- What's up, guys?
First and foremost, thanks
for watching the daily vlog.
The speed and intensity
of this is gonna be fun.
Anyway, keeping an
eye on this episode,
make sure you pay
attention to, you know,
when to let go, not to
try to control everything,
recognizing how much
control you do have,
and also recognizing when
to let go of control.
What I mean by that, as
you'll see in the London
All Hands On meeting.
I don't need London's
office to act the way
LA's office acts, like the
way New York's office acts.
So many CEOs and
leaders try to do that.
I think it's a huge mistake.
I think you need
to let the leaders
within those
organizations do their thing,
and then just the
thematics of everything,
which is, I just think
way too many people
are paying attention to
macro trends and think that
politics, or leaders,
or organizations,
or platforms, or websites,
or other human beings
control their outcome.
You control your shit.
Now watch this.
(melancholy piano music)
So I just landed in
London from the U.S.
and just saw the election news.
You know, just my two cents.
So many people
are hitting me up,
so just something to point to
when I get the emails
or the questions.
I was born in Soviet Russia,
and I love America
very, very much.
And my true belief
is that, you know,
I have lots of texts from
friends that are scared
and very worried, and texts from
friends who are
elated and optimistic.
And, you know, this is what
always happens in America.
We're very much
divided on a lot of
fiscal and
social issues, and so,
I just wanna
remind everybody that,
unlike Soviet Russia, we
have so much more control.
And, you know, some will
say that's slipping away,
and I understand where
everybody's coming from,
but for me and my family,
I'm on the offense.
I don't believe
any man or woman,
as the president
of the United States
is gonna dictate the
outcome of my life, and so,
I will always fight
to love everybody.
Team human, not just U.S.
That's something I'm
very passionate about.
And I will fight for
meritocracy and capitalism,
because I believe in it.
And so, I just hope that
everybody takes a step back
and realizes I'm an optimist.
I just am.
And so, we're gonna fight,
and fight for our families,
and be in full control,
as we really are.
(laughing)
- I was at the hospital.
And I thought,
I have to get you.
Cause I sent you a
Snapchat on Monday
about getting the book, and
I wanted to come meet you.
So I want to do
some volunteer work,
I want to get
involved with the company
in some way, shape, or
form, whether it's cleaning.
Just to get entry level.
- Send me an e-mail, send
me an e-mail to Gary...
Do you have e-mail?
- I was uh,--
- Alright, I need to grab this.
- No worries.
- Let's take a quick picture.
- Please, okay, fantastic Gary.
- Send me an e-mail and say
I'm the guy that met you.
- Where do I send it to?
- Gary@vaynermedia
- Okay.
- And I'm gonna
see what I can do.
- Thank you, Gary, thank you.
- Take care.
- [Rafal] Take care.
- Thank you very much.
- [Man With Crutches]
Have a fantastic day Gary.
- You too my friend,
feel better, get better.
- [Eric] I'm just gonna let
you talk to him for 5 minutes
and see if something...
- Okay--
- [Eric] Flies there.
And then we
go back to the office.
One thing before
I forget, so 5:30
we do like an "All Hand"
type of thing with wine,
like we'll do wine Wednesday,
like we did last time
when you were here.
- [Gary] Hey, how are you?
How's it going?
- Harry, do we have a corkscrew?
- Even in times where
uncertainty or things
of that nature,
I'm just incapable of
not being optimistic.
One of the things I've
always prided Vayner in
and my life in is work
ethic and kind of the
stomach for adversity and so...
(laughing)
Anybody, I mean you don't
have to ask a Vayner question.
Anybody want to talk about
a question about the market?
Meaning the market as,
Snapchat, or...
- [Man] Are you
supposed to tell us why we're
not gonna to talk
about our brand?
- Eric and I talk
a little bit about that,
so since you brought it up,
I think one of the great
advantages is being quiet.
I'm loud,
but Vayner's quiet, right?
And, that has been very much
something that I think has
benefited us as such a
fast growing company.
I'm not worried about
you telling some secret.
There's no secret.
There's nothing we're
doing that's so secret.
I think that, we're gonna win.
And I think that when
you're gonna win something
and tear down the establishment,
you have to have some
equal balance of humility
to the marketplace because
I'm surely not doing that.
I'm going to A&amp;A in front
of the entire market
and telling them
that they're fuck faces
and we're gonna kill them.
(group laughter)
So, I need the machine
to kind of have that...
The level of pride I have
that this is an actual steak
that compliments the
sizzle that I put out into
the world really matters.
(group laughter)
Oh you want some?
Sorry I thought,
I gave you the first one,
I thought you had it.
Here, let me pour it for you.
- I was gonna go for red.
- Here you go.
- Thanks for the red.
- You're welcome.
- Thanks so much.
- Got it. Yes, I wasn't thinking
red-white dynamic, sorry.
Shame on me.
So, what's ironic is,
I think that the studio
which is in our old office,
a couple blocks from Vayner
feels like a million
miles away too.
Truth is, that's why I
believe so much in you guys,
like that dream of,
it feels the same,
as the same way of laddering
up creative to the same pillar.
It's not real.
It's not real, but that
doesn't mean it's wrong.
I genuinely think of it as
the United States of America.
Which is, I think
New York is DC, or at least
my office is DC, and
I believe that this is Texas
and Eric is the governor.
I think this aspiration of
making it feel,
it's always evolving.
New York doesn't feel
like the New York
that you guys worked in.
Like, you're not the same
when you're four and seven.
I have a four and
a seven year old.
They're different, ya
know, and that's okay.
People that get
mad about a tactic
start saying we've changed,
or I don't believe.
Like, if you love your
mother, she may do something
you don't like, but that
doesn't mean you don't
love your mother anymore, right?
So, I want it to
always live and breathe.
It always will.
London doesn't feel like London
to the first seven people.
It's definitely not gonna
feel like London in the next
three months, four months,
when this is double the size.
Like, some of you are gonna
make jokes like, I've been
here for five months and
I'm a veteran, right?
(group laughter)
That's the game right?
I mean right?
That's what it is so,
this is why I'm drilling
the honey empire thing
over and over and
I'll be drilling it more.
There's only two
things that I care about:
That we're the kindest to
each other ever in this game
and that we don't let that
come at the expense of
being very good at your craft.
- Just walled you on the
last time he was here.
- That it?
- No, he just wasn't
paying attention.
- Hey how are you?
- Good to see you man.
- I like your show.
- I'll send it to you.
- You comin' in?
("POKOJ" by BAMF)
The reason very few
people win at optimism
'cause you have to
be so much better.
It's very interesting
thing, I know you get it.
Cool, right?
- I totally get it.
- It's hard, that's why
nobody sells what I sell.
It's so hard.
- Can we get a picture with you?
- Funny thing is, I was
watching your video.
2008, when you said the
House of Cards shit,
and I was like,
shit, this was 2008.
I've only heard
about you this year,
you don't seem upset about that.
- [Gary] It's patience, patience.
- Exactly.
- [Gary] It's hard!
- I know!
- How did you stay patient?
- Because I know
it's the only option.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- You have to switch
your mind to thinking
it's a negative,
I thought it was a positive.
- Yeah.
- [Woman] So like, end goal,
like did you succeed
or did you not.
And the thing is, I get it man.
- [Gary] You're empathetic.
- [Woman] Yes!
- [Gary] To where he's
coming from, I get it.
That's why I'm not good
at being an assistant
or community manager,
you understand?
- And I need to hear
from you, that's fine.
- Fine.
- [Woman] Really fine.
I'm not doing it tonight.
- You can email me every day.
(laughs)
- Well, I can make you smile.
- Awesome.
- Great, love you.
- Cool, love you more.
- I like...
- Where am I going?
I wanna see if,
I feel like this person
wants to say hello.
- Hi, huge fan.
- Hi, thank you mate.
- Actually, I was standing
here didn't know what to say.
- (laughs) No worries, I saw
you hovering, what's your name?
- Montes.
- Montes, very nice man.
- I'm actually, like right
now, I'm studying business
and I'm doing marketing.
I'm working at a startup
doing marketing and right now
starting a company as well.
- Good for you man, good luck.
- The thing is, we're doing
like, we found with a friend,
we're doing this kind of
advertising for Instagram.
It's a very complex
structure and now
we're looking for
a tax attorney.
We don't know how to do, with
the payments and everything.
- Well, send me an e-mail
to Gary@vaynermedia,
I'll send you some people
that can you help you.
- Are you serious?
- I'm dead serious.
- Oh my God, thanks.
- Gary@vanyermedia,
I'll try to hook you up.
- Thank you.
- Take care.
(shivers)
Let's make positivity louder.
- So, question for the room,
like, how do we all fix that?
- Easy, doing it.
- Right, we can all do it,
individually,
so my question is--
- No, no, but do you?
No, no, that's the punchline.
It's one brick at a time.
- [Eric] There's a step
before that which is...
- Actually believing it.
- [Eric] Wanting to...
- No, no, actually believing it.
- [Eric] Sure, acknowledgement,
and then there's the action.
- Yeah, that's right.
My content is pretty
happy and I'm a happy dude.
- Do you have a type of
engagement?
- What's that? (laughing)
Do you know what's funny?
Negativity is a lot easier to
sell, that's why it's working.
What I do for a
living is much harder.
I'm trying to win on positivity,
which is the hardest sell.
- If you talk
about the news now,
if they just sat there
going, "everything's great",
it doesn't resonate with people.
- First of all they're wrong.
You're either on
offense or you're not.
Like, to me, dwelling is
super not interesting.
It's got zero value.
You need to be thoughtful,
you need to understand,
you need to not have
too much ego to lack the
humility that why
did we get here.
But, dwelling?
I'm not interested in
dwelling of what just
happened in our countries.
I'm interested in
being on the offense to
A, start closing the
gap back to the social.
I care about the social impacts.
I sent an e-mail to the
entire company today
of an emoji heart, that was it.
Or I think I wrote something,
like "I love you" or something.
But, the e-mails that
I got back were so insane.
Like, just like,
people needed it.
It takes so little to do,
it's so easy to say,
"hey", or wink at somebody,
or just smile,
but it's not.
Because you actually
have to believe it.
And people don't
actually believe it.
This is negative, like,
I want to be on the offense
of positivity, not dwell and
understand how we got here.
1:02 in the morning.
London.
Good productive day, nice 45
minute with my homie, Shawn.
And, it's time to
get some sleep.
Alright, Shawn, see you later.
- [Shawn] Alright man.